making his 11th start of the season his
first here at salem field he was very
good last year in five starts in buffalo
with an era just over two it's coming
off his fifth win of the season it might
have been his finest performance
altuve goes after the first pitch and
pops it high in the center one pitch one
out for ryu
there's a big curveball left it in the
air again another lazy fly ball two up
two down for rio as korea flies out
there and indus
ground ball to third panic acid long
throw in plenty of time
you're gonna see right-hander zach
granky for this first game of this road
trip 12 starts this season he has thrown
in 73 and two-thirds innings
last three games he has pitched in he's
been very good astros going two-and-one
and he has a 2.45 era in those last
three outings
one of the better hitting teams in all
of baseball marcus simeon picks on the
first pitch and drives one to center
field back on its straw right up against
the wall
it's center field in salem field puts it
away for the first out
simeon gave it a ride
as he shoots one to right field and that
ball is caught
hanging up for kyle tucker for the
second out here in the bottom of the
first
how about this zach grenkey with a quick
one two three inning i mean quick he
only needed four pitches to get through
the first keep it up
there's another fly ball into right
hernandez has room right on the edge of
the warning track hauls it in
[Applause]
alvarez to the plate and that is
something we have seen consistently
who gets it on the outside corner here's
another fly bar takes courier right to
the edge of the warning trap and he
hauls it in
swing and a miss got gretchik for the
first out zach picks up his first
strikeout
still on the injured list the 0-1 runner
takes off pitches low thrown on the
second by maldonado and out at second
teosa hernandez gunned down by the
machete
caught stealing there's a ball shot the
other way but right at the third baseman
oled miss diaz in the ship
cormier hits it high and to the right
field quarter to oscar hernandez is
there he's got room and he makes a catch
[Music]
maldonado pops it up guerrero comes down
from first and takes charge makes the
catch
so altuve given the free pass that's the
first walk of the ball game and that'll
bring up carlos correa
that one popped high in the air on the
infield vladimir guerrero jr waits for
it
no balls and two strikes
and this one's hit well to right field
slicing toward the line is tucker he
makes the catch
but he did a great job of tricking
teles right there
maybe sitting on the off speed we
haven't seen much off speed in this game
so far from zach drankie not throwing a
ton of pitches but locating that
fastball beautifully down and away
in this sitting and that ball hit high
in the air to pretty deep left field
back on it is chas mccormick
right on the edge of the warding track
puts it away for the final out and
here's jordan alvarez who smoked one to
first base as last time up but grounded
out
that ball smoked to center field back on
it goes grichik and that ball's off the
base of the wall and just sits there
you're not into second base easily i'll
let miss diaz will score
jordan alvarez the rbi double the astros
on the board first one to nothing
with the one to nothing lead bottom of
the fourth grinky's first pitch to
simeon is driven to right field back on
it tucker he's going to have room just
in front of the warning track
and that's one pitch one out here in the
fourth inning for zach grinky
that ball into center field hanging up
for straw who puts it away
brando grichik struck out on a breaking
ball his first time up
here's the 2-2 breaking ball got him
strike three as gretchen goes down
that ball hit sharply past the shortstop
beau bashed into left field miles straw
enjoying his time in buffalo he's a
perfect two for two and he's going to
get to second base with a lead off
double straw
in on the edge of the grass for jose
altschubi
well two bay fly ball center field
plenty deep enough to score straw with
his speed it's actually drifting to
right now so the catch made by tasker
hernandez
either way straw is going to score it's
a two-nothing game on the sac fly by
jose altube two to nothing houston
here's carlos correa
and correa hits this in the air to left
fairly deep down toward the line guriel
going back looking up see you later
carlos correa goes deep and the astros
go up three to nothing correa's ninth
home run of the year
beautiful by correa showing how much
power he has how strong he is
the one one to yuli and that's a ground
ball up the middle and in the center for
a base hit over toward left center goes
gridchuck and guriel's trying for two as
gritchuk didn't handle it cleanly and
yuli gets the second man the astros are
taking 90 feet at every opportunity and
the astros have loaded the bases and now
it's maldonado looking for a two out hit
and martine sends one to left field back
goes lourdes guriel jr near the wall
this ball's gone grand slam martin
maldonado baldi scores four with a grand
slam
and the astros lead seven to nothing
that one coming right back to maldi
might have gotten it a little bit off
the end of the bat but did a great job
of extending on that and getting it
here's the lead miss diaz he is playing
at third base tonight
oled miss hits one to left field lourdes
curiel finds it in the night and he
watches that one go out oled miss diaz
third consecutive inning with an astros
home run and it's now eight to nothing
here's randall grichik he struck out
twice on a grinky curveball both times
getting him with the curveball
it goes after the first pitch hits it
high and deep and this one's gonna go
he threw him in the fastball that time
and he might want to rethink that pitch
as randall bridgette has hit another
home run that's home run number 12 for
randall
baldy goes the other way what a night
for martin maldonado base hit to right
around third comes mccormick he's going
to score straw to third
astros now lead this game nine to one
[Music]
without two bay up the middle that's
gonna be a base hit astros in double
figures it is now 10-1 and still nobody
out for correa
that ball drilled deep to left field
that's a rocket that's gone carlos
correa a three-run home run two home
runs on the night for correa a three-run
shot
13-1 astros it is all smiles for the
houston astros zach ranki back out there
trying to throw his first complete game
of the season cranky nods in agreement
with maldonado and delivers a one-two
and pachette skies this one out to left
center racing over and making the grab
chas mccormick one out
towards second diaz shows he could play
any position on the infield
fly ball left center field straw will
make the call
and the catch zach grenkey a complete
game for the first time going nine
innings since june 7th of 2016